[Music]  well nevada just hitting a major vaccine  milestone 50 percent of eligible  nevadans are fully vaccinated as of  yesterday more than 2.8 million vaccine  dosing doses that is had been given  around 60 percent of residents 12 and  older have initiated getting the vaccine  meaning they have got one dose so let's  take a look at a quick look that is at  the latest numbers nevada's positivity  rate down  by the day we are at 14.9 percent right  now clark county though a little lower  at 14.4 meantime the county is reporting  213 cases per every 100 thousand of us  over the past week that number needs to  be below 100 for any restrictions to  start easing up our goal is of course to  keep you informed we have this qr code  which you can scan right now on your tv  screen just pull out your phone open  your camera  you try to take a picture and the link  pops on up that will take you to  8newsnow.com where we have more about  the numbers